dude you know what we gotta actually
talk about though mm for a little bit at
least 20 to 30 minutes is Jake but no
you know not that Hobbes in cha oh yeah
yeah good movie man no we talked about
this before and I was saying like action
movie coverage is hilarious because they
they [ __ ] that amount of money is
stupid it's ridiculous thank you they
get they get like background guys
reloading guns yeah they're telling like
15 different plot lines look at the
credits for those movies are [ __ ] so
funny it's like first unit second unit
third unit fourth unit fifth unit it's
like how many [ __ ] people we have
like a background 18 yeah yeah I got
back round BTM and like so would [ __ ]
going it's just so much movie it's most
movie I've I've ever watched it's so
much and every scene is so scene yeah
it's like dude that when I'm watching
the one where they find out that she
when she links with Hobbes and Shaw yeah
no Hobbes his sister whatever and she is
the virus yeah
and they basically their conversation
ensues and it's it's they figure out she
has the virus yeah that she's gonna die
if they don't fix whatever the [ __ ]
happens and they weigh all the options
either they kill her immediately hmm and
you know like eviscerate her body you
know or they have to find the machine
yeah and extract it yeah but the machine
is in an impossible place to get to yes
there's this scientist but what that all
happens in like 15 seconds yeah
and so she goes from thinking that she's
gonna die to to thinking she's not gonna
die and then thinking okay actually I
should probably die too oh wait there's
a there's a chance that I'm gonna live
and then like okay we're gonna go for
this all while his her brothers right
they're going through that same wave of
emotion of my sister might die yeah this
is all happening like 15 [ __ ] seconds
yeah yeah and I'm watching this thing
like just sweating and it's funny at the
same time I'm like how are they doing
this
yeah they they just manage to make every
every dialogue every piece of dialogue
feels really serious for 10 seconds and
then it had
some comedic [ __ ] with an yeah yeah and
I hate how like AI driven all the
dialogue is yeah we have to go into the
heavily fortified thing with the thing
inside with the Machine with the doctor
bad dick or she dies
no one dies on my watch it was like it
was like a it was like a romance comedy
and like a family comedy but also like a
buddy like these hot film these guys are
also best for they become best friend
also a rock film and also a Rasta home
film and also a film about Samoa yeah
yeah and also the British super agent
film all-in-one somehow they [ __ ]
pulled that literally Tony movies and
when I let's just sit when at the end
when they couple all those cars to their
helicopter dude you know what watching
that movie is it's just it's just you
saying come on yeah yeah 40 times yeah
come on yeah come on then by the end of
it you're like [ __ ] come on yeah come
on yeah yeah great [ __ ] movie is it
that with a couple all those cars you're
like oh this is part of the Fast and
Furious franchise yeah yeah yeah oh you
don't get that until yeah 89 90 you're
like oh [ __ ] that's yeah that's the
big and it dude I love how first of all
I'm not going to say the rock is a bad
actor but I love when he does a movie
just to be the rock yeah yeah yeah
like he just to be buff and yeah and to
be like hey come over here I'm gonna be
your ass yeah like when they do the
little sequence when they walk through
the two sides and like like like Jason
Statham's character like he goes like
this intense like karate yell can ya
segment and the rock is just the rock
walking on the other side yeah and there
are tons of old wrestling fans who are
like goddamn that is [ __ ] cool just be
the rock do you smell it yeah that's all
there dude is
watching him be the rock in a buddy-cop
filling me in a movie about Samoa and
like the fact that they went back to
Samoa and she liked that it's just I
feel like the rock wrote that no because
it was his real mom no completely he yet
just they were gonna make that film and
then he's like well if you want to be
part of this movie I need a free
vacation to Samoa and what is he moving
Samoa yeah also we have to write in the
fact that I haven't seen my family in a
while because I really haven't like he
would that beef with his brother was
real dude that whole in fact this
brother was a [ __ ] car mechanic and
he fixed this you fix this machine right
that's gonna Dara that's gonna like it's
an antidote for like the world's most
powerful virus yeah bro what why did you
just call him to start yeah what'd you
do all the other stuff what he's just
hit him up to build a bomb to blow that
whole place up or build it clearly he's
smarter [ __ ] I would have loved it if
they were like we have to go into this
heavily fortified fortress to get the
machine to extract a virus from her
sister or she dies
and then chases Taylor just looks at his
sister and he shoots her look done mate
done the rocks look up its credit and
Hobbes his sister is replaying him
shooting her in the [ __ ] brain we
have to go to the fortress or save your
super doesn't even wait for him to
finish I was thinking the whole day
right at least at the end I was thinking
like this is the just the most the
writers were like how could we write a
movie about these two guys these two
[ __ ] alpha males becoming friends
yeah in the most absurd way possible
yeah what's the craziest two hours yeah
good right leading up to these two
[ __ ] alpha males just putting us
either differences being like we should
work together actually dude I watched
two movies I forget the director's name
I feel like an [ __ ] but I watched two
Lina and I watched two movies directed
by him and then rock no no the director
Hobson shot oh no and then Lina
mentioned that they hired him for an
Apple spot okay and the spot was him
shooting like a snowball action sequence
with the iPhone it's actually pretty
[ __ ] crazy because you know that's
the one thing that you take for granted
in a film like that you're just like oh
this is so much money and clearly this
was easy and like that dude the the spot
he directed for this snowball fight is
[ __ ] crazy really it's crazy it feels
exactly like a Hobbs and Shawn movie or
like a high budget action film with just
an iPhone like the way he thinks about
like getting angles and like capturing
action you're just like yo this is
[ __ ] yeah and like the way he's like
thinking about moving the camera and
stuff so as Goofy's that movie was like
that dude I give a lot of credit to cuz
to think in the way he does oh yeah I
can't fight scenes I was like how could
you ever even see this in your head
mmhmm yeah yeah if they were cohesive
like they all made sense and there's so
much [ __ ] happening mmm in again like
the 1520 seconds yeah segments yeah that
to actually like have an audience member
be like oh oh he threw that guy over
this shoulder yeah then he actually came
through with this arm yeah and all that
[ __ ] totally made sense to me it's like
that's so hard to do it with the 30 cuts
that happen like yeah there's so much
cutting in those movies yeah yeah for it
to all not only like [ __ ] make sense
but the fact that like they can take
something so complex and like like make
you retain the whole movie yeah you know
what I mean yeah like it's one thing to
like like watch the fight and be like
understanding what happened bully get
all that's it to walk out of the movie
buddy you see Hobbes and Shaw why was it
I miss foot it's pretty cool I mean the
rock and Statham they start well
and then they go to Samoa and yeah
they'd be like which movie do you want
yeah yeah it's a it's a six act movie so
you'd be very specific about what part
of the movie you want to know yeah bro
I'm glad you watched it that [ __ ] is so
that puts every three-part [ __ ] like
Harry Potter part 1 you know all that
look at it puts that [ __ ] to shame get
out of here you can tell they disproved
you can tell 9 stories yeah the studio
was like um if we gave you a billion
dollars we really don't think you could
spend it the director is like give me a
second
hey yeah give me one second here's this
pitch deck is just how about seven
movies in one movie the Hollywood is
like oh yeah oh yeah drops is great
that's like this [ __ ] big but it's
all just [ __ ] action it is I didn't
like I didn't even think about it that
way when if when I first watched it that
it it is 17 movies and one yeah I
remember watching it and the Samoa part
happened and I was thinking like this is
a whole other [ __ ] movie I know I
know just transition to it was so
[ __ ] funny and like slick and like
like this is the fact that they they
they called Kevin Hart they're like hey
man just want to thank you for that
plane you sent oh yeah and I was just as
a viewer I was like oh yeah that
happened yeah yeah I believe that
totally and I don't like wait that was
so like they didn't even [ __ ] zero
footage [ __ ] private jet that they
took that little sequence between the
three of those pretty funny I was a
hilarious they were Ryan Reynolds was
really funny too yeah yeah the movie was
like Nemec funny bro I don't even know
how you father planning for a film like
that yeah off yeah [ __ ] off anyway one
of the wines from your minibar yeah
you